.
THE SATELLITE AMAGES OF A LONG
LINE YOU HAVE CARS FLEEING THE
CITY.
AND NOW AS PROMISE THE, MY
INTERVIEW WITH DEFENSE SECRETARY
LLOYD AUSTIN.
A MILITARY MAN WHO GENERALLY
KEEPS A LOW PROFILE, BUT THIS,
THIS IS TIME THAT HAS THRUST HIM
REALLY ON TO CENTER STAGE,
TRAVELING FROM CITY TO CITY IN
EUROPE TO RALLY OPPOSITION TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S WAR UKRAINE.
AND WE GOT SOME SPECIAL ACCESS
THROUGHOUT THE SECRETARY'S DAY
TODAY.
I WAS ABLE TO SPEAK WITH HIM ON
THE PLANE WHILE EN ROUTE TO
BULGARIA.
>> SO GOOD TO SEE YOU.
HE IS SHOWING MORALE AND
DEFENSES IN EASTERN EUROPE AND
WE WERE THERE AS HE WELCOMED, HE
WAS WELCOMED AT THE TRAINING
AREA IN BULGARIA.
HERE IS OUR INTERVIEW.
>> THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS.
I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
WE FLEW TO BULGARIA FROM
SLOVAKIA WHERE YESTERDAY YOU
REITERATED YOUR OPPOSITION TO A
NO-FLY ZONE.
IF THAT IS A COMMITMENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, HOW DO YOU CLOSE
THE SKIES OVER UKRAINE?
>> DON, THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
VERY CLEAR ABOUT THE FACT THAT
WE WON'T HAVE TROOPS ENGAGED IN
COME ABOUT THE WITH RUSSIA IN
UKRAINE.
IN ORDER TO EFFECT OR PUT INTO
PLACE A NO-FLY ZONE, WE'D HAVE
TO CONTROL THE SKIES AND THAT
WOULD MEAN THAT WE'D HAVE TO
ENGAGE RUSSIAN AIRCRAFT.
WE'D ALSO HAVE TO TAKE OUT OUR
RUSSIAN ANTI-AIRCRAFT SYSTEMS IN
UKRAINE, IN BELARUS AND ALSO IN
RUSSIA.
SO THAT WOULD MEAN THAT WE ARE
IN COMBAT WITH RUSSIA.
THESE ARE TWO NUCLEAR-POWERED
COUNTRIES THAT NOBODY WANTS TO
SEE ENGAGE IN A CONFLICT.
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE REGION.
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE WORLD.
>> IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
POSITION RIGHT NOW FOR THE U.S.
IS NOT TO ENGAGE DIRECTLY WITH
RUSSIA?
IS THAT THE MOST IMPORTANT
POSITION RIGHT NOW?
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE IN ITS EFFORT TO DEFEND
ITS COUNTRY AND PROTECT ITS
SOVEREIGNTY.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN DOING THIS,
WE HAVE ALL BEEN INSPIRED BY THE
COURAGE, THEIR TENACITY, THEIR
AGILITY.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
FOCUSED ON.
WE ARE FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE
THAT WE DO EVERYTHING TO PROTECT
NATO.
AND SO YOU HAVE SEEN US RAPIDLY
DEPLOY FORCES TO THE EASTERN --
THE COUNTRIES ON THE EASTERN
EDGE THERE, EASTERN FLAUNG, AND
YOU HAVE SEEN US REASSURE OUR
ALLIES.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
WILL -- WE ARE COMMITTED TO
ARTICLE 5 AND WE ARE GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR POWER TO
DEFEND EVERY INCH OF NATO
TERRITORY.
>> WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT NOT
GETTING INVOLVED, RUSSIAN
MISSILES HIT LVIV.
43 MILES FROM POLAND'S BORDER.
DO YOU CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT
IT'S POSSIBLE TO ENGAGE IN THIS
WITHOUT DIRECT INVOLVEMENT,
NATO'S DIRECT INVOLVEMENT, WHICH
WOULD MEAN U.S. INVOLVEMENT?
>> AGAIN, DON, YOU KNOW, OUR
FOCUS IS MAKING SURE THAT WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE.
AND CERTAINLY I DON'T WANT TO
GET INVOLVED IN ANY
HYPOTHETICALS.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S HEALTH.
I THINK WE HAVE BEEN CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT WE ARE FOCUSED ON HERE.
>> THE U.S. HAS MADE IT VERY
CLEAR THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
INVOLVED IN A PROCESS OF GIVING
JETS TO UKRAINE.
DO YOU SUPPORT OTHER COUNTRIES
DOING IT OR ENCOURAGE -- EITHER
ENCOURAGE OTHER COUNTRIES TO DO
IT AS LONG AS THERE IS NO U.S.
INVOLVEMENT?
>> DON, WHAT OTHER COUNTRIES DO,
I MEAN THAT'S THEIR CHOICE.
AND THE UNITED STATES CERTAINLY
DOES NOT STAND IN THE WAY OF
OTHER COUNTRIES PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE.
BUT, AGAIN, WE'RE GOING TO
REMAIN FOCUSED ON THOSE THINGS
THAT WE KNOW ARE MAKING A
DIFFERENCE AND WHAT'S MAKING A
DIFFERENCE IN THIS FIGHT FOR THE
UKRAINIANS IS THE PROVISION OF
ANTI-AIRCRAFT SYSTEMS, THE
PROVISION OF ARMORED SYSTEMS AND
ALSO THINGS THAT -- OTHER THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN EFFECTIVE ARE THE
EMPLOYMENT OF DRONES.
SO YOU HAVE HEARD THE PRESIDENT
SAY MOST RECENTLY WHAT WE'RE
DOING, THE KIND OF THINGS WE ARE
PROVIDING.
HE JUST -- WE JUST SIGNED --
JUST PROVIDED AUTHORIZATION TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL $1 BILLION
WORTH OF SECURITY FORCES
SYSTEMS.
THAT'S REMARKABLE.
>> WHAT IS YOUR ASSESSMENT OF
RUSSIAN FORCES NOW?
ARE THEY STALLED?
ARE THEY REGROUPING SO THAT THEY
CAN INCREASE THEIR ASSAULT,
INCREASE THEIR VIOLENCE ON
UKRAINE?
WHAT IS YOUR ASSESSMENT OF THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY?
>> IT'S HARD TO TELL, DON.
THEY HAVE NOT PROGRESSED AS
QUICKLY AS THEY WOULD HAVE LIKED
TO.
I NEW THEY ENVISIONED THEY WOULD
MOVE RAPIDLY AND VERY QUICKLY,
SEIZE THE CAPITAL CITY.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO
THAT.
THEY'VE STRUGGLED WITH
LOGISTICS.
SO WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER OF
MISSTEPS ALONG THE WAY.
I DON'T SEE EVIDENCE OF GOOD
EMPLOYMENT OF TACTICAL
INTELLIGENCE.
I DON'T SEE INTEGRATION OF, YOU
KNOW, AIR CAPABILITY WITH THE
GROUND MANEUVER.
SO THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT WE WOULD EXPECT TO HAVE
SEEN THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN.
AND THE RUSSIANS REALLY HAVE HAD
SOME PROBLEMS.
MANY OF THEIR ASSUMPTIONS HAVE
NOT PROVEN TO BE TRUE AS THEY
ENTERED THIS FIGHT.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS SPEAKING
WITH XI JINPING AND WE ARE
GETTING REPORTING THAT RUSSIA
HAS BEEN ASKING CHINA FOR DRONES
AND FOR HELP.
WHAT HAPPENS?
DO YOU THINK CHINA WILL STAY OUT
OF THIS AND WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY
DON'T?
>> AGAIN, DON'T WANT TO
SPECULATE OR GET INVOLVED IN
HYPOTHETICALS.
I WOULD HOPE THAT CHINA WOULD
NOT SUPPORT THIS DESPICABLE ACT
BY PUTIN.
I WOULD HOPE THAT THEY WOULD
RECOGNIZE A NEED TO RESPECT
SOVEREIGN TERRITORY.
AND SO HARD TO SAY WHAT THEY
WILL DO, BUT, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
BEEN CLEAR THAT IF THEY DO THAT,
WE THINK THAT'S A BAD CHOICE.
>> PUTIN HAS RAISED A SPECTOR OF
POSSIBLE USE OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
I WANT TO FIRST ASK YOU ABOUT
CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
WE'RE GETTING INTELLIGENCE OR
WE'RE HEARING FROM INTELLIGENCE
PEOPLE SAYING THAT RUSSIA MAY
USE CHEMICAL WEAPONS AND THEN
BLAME UKRAINE FALSELY.
THE PRESIDENT SAID IF THAT
HAPPENS THEY WILL PAY A HEAVY
PRICE.
WHAT IS A HEAVY PRICE?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, AGAIN I DON'T
WANT TO SPECULATE ABOUT WHETHER
OR NOT, YOU KNOW, WHAT THE PRICE
WOULD BE.
I WOULD SAY IF HE USED CHEMICAL
WEAPONS, THERE WOULD BE, YOU
KNOW, A NEGATIVE REACTION FROM
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY,
DON.
IN TERMS OF WHAT KIND OF
RESPONSES THAT WOULD COME ABOUT
As A RESULT OF THAT FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY, LEFT TO
BE SEEN.
BUT AGAIN WE CERTAINLY WOULD
HOPE THAT HE WOULD CHOOSE NOT TO
DO THAT.
PUTIN COULD END THIS TODAY.
HE HAS HAD A NUMBER OF CHOICES,
A NUMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES ALONG
THE WAY TO DE-ESCALATE AND TO
OFF-RAMP AND HE HAS NOT DONE
THAT.
SO WE ARE HERE TODAY BECAUSE OF
THE CHOICE OF ONE MAN.
HE CERTAINLY HAS OPTIONS RIGHT
NOW.
ONE OF THOSE OPTIONS IS TO
DE-ESCALATE AND TO SEEK
DIPLOMATIC SOLUTION TO THIS.
>> WHAT ABOUT TACTICAL?
WHAT ABOUT THE USE OF TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS, HE MAY USE
SO-CALLED SMALL NUKES.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THAT?
>> AGAIN, THE USE OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS IS A THING THAT NOBODY
WANTS TO SEE.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, ANY KIND OF
EXCESSIVE RHETORIC ABOUT NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AND THE EMPLOYMENT OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS IS NOT HELPFUL.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT AS FAR
AS WE ARE CONCERNED, WE ARE
CONFIDENT IN OUR CURRENT STANCE
AND IN OUR CAPABILITIES AND OUR
ABILITY TO DEFEND OURSELVES.
>> IS THE U.S. GIVING TACTICAL
ADVICE OR ANY ADVICE, ANY U.S.
FORCES HELPING THE UKRAINIAN
MILITARY?
>> DON, WHAT YOU SEE US DOING IS
PROVIDING A LOT OF SECURITY
FORCE ASSISTANCE IN TERMS OF
EQUIPMENT.
WE'RE TALKING TO OUR
COUNTERPARTS EVERY DAY, YOU
KNOW.
AND, HOPEFULLY, I WILL GET A
CHANCE TO TALK TO THE UKRAINIAN
MINISTER OF DEFENSE SOON.
BUT THERE IS ALWAYS -- THERE IS
A CONSTANT DIALOGUE ONGOING
BETWEEN US AND THEIR LEADERSHIP,
AND ALSO THE LEADERSHIP OF OTHER
COUNTRIES AS WELL.
I TALKED TO MY COLLEAGUES, OTHER
MINISTERS OF DEFENSE.
THEY ARE ENGAGING THE UKRAINIAN
MUNSTER OF DEFENSE ON A DAILY
BASIS.
>> WHAT ABOUT SPECIAL FORCES?
ARE THEY HELPING THE UKRAINIAN
MILITARY?
ARE THEY IN UKRAINE AT ALL
HELPING?
>> WE DON'T HAVE ANY FORCES IN
UKRAINE.
>> IT HAS BEEN NOTED, SUN T SFL
U SAYS BUILD A GOLDEN BRIDGE
ACROSS.
WHAT IS PUTIN'S GOLDEN BRIDGE?
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS END
SOMETHING?
>> BY HE -- WE'RE HERE BECAUSE
OF HIS DECISION TO LAUNCH THIS
ATTACK.
HE CAN MAKE A DECISION TODAY TO
END THIS AND SEEK A DIPLOMATIC
SOLUTION.
HE HAS HAD A NUMBER OF
OPPORTUNITIES ALONG THE WAY.
HE HAS OPPORTUNITIES TODAY TO
DECIDE DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
THIS IS NOT GOING WELL FOR HIM
ON THE BATTLEFIELD AND THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT ARE